6 43 a bit of breaking news here the
goat says he's done for real this time
for real yeah for reals Quarterback Tom
Brady announcing his retirement in a
video posted on social media earlier
this morning take a listen
won't be long-winded I think you only
get one super emotional retirement essay
and I used mine up last year so
Tom was a little more concise this time
this morning he simply said I'm done now
there were some rumors he might join the
Las Vegas Raiders but nah he's done he's
sitting on the beach he's enjoying
things he ends his career as a
seven-time Super Bowl champion five-time
MVP a 23-year career the greatest of all
time Tom Brady says he's done truly
uncertain honestly just there you go